spring in Luke Walton the new Lakers
head coach former warriors assistant who
joins us now Luke congrats where are you
i am down in manhattan beach day and
appreciate you having me on how close
are we to d-day with your wife ah two
days away due date wise but obviously
that can come at any anytime now first
baby the second one oh okay all right
then this is old hat yeah you're a
veteran yeah yeah yeah this is easy mg
go we got this there if she called she
said right now honey let's go I gotta go
right now would you finish the interview
mom is gonna see here i think i think i
have enough time with it is the house
you got names picked out yeah we do but
you know i'm not allowed to say any of
them i told i told my coat the coaching
staff in Golden State one of the names
and they crushed it so now that names
off the list don't allow no no that was
part of the plan behind it because I
wasn't that into that name anyway but uh
I'm no longer allowed to share it the
names boy or girl we uh we don't find
out hmm yeah we just we wait and see
what happens how about a how about magic
for a boy magic magic Waltons hmm i'll
think about no you won't know you won't
know how about stem for a boy or Steph
for a girl there we go both ways with
that one yeah um yeah um i don't i don't
know if that's I think it's a little
late to add that's right okay uh but you
have this could be I mean think about
how crazy the high and low of 7 days
could be
losing Game seven to the birth of
another child the Lakers job too that's
crazy little roller coaster here for you
it is um you know it's uh there's a lot
of stuff that needs to be done and you
know they were all they are all exciting
exciting things and unfortunately the
first one of those which was trying to
win a championship this year didn't
happen but still an amazing year but
yeah now we we had a 24 hour turnaround
to get down to LA and start this job and
we also got the draft on thursday which
is also the due date and we got free
agency and staff to hire and all all
sorts of things going on at a that are
that are exciting it's just like you
said it's a little bit of a emotional
roller coaster around here Reggie Miller
said a couple of weeks ago he thought
something was wrong with stuff that he
might need surgery in the offseason can
you share how banged up he was and is
there surgery in the offseason do you
think for stuff I'm not sure I may I
know he's uh his knee was obviously
hurting him but you know Steph never
complains about about it he just he
continued to show up and play knew that
he'd deal with it and deal with whatever
he had to whether that was rest or
whatever him and the doctors think is
best this offseason you know I had to
leave literally at ten a.m. the next
morning so I haven't really had time to
talk to too many people up there since
I've left I don't really know where
where he's standing on that would you be
surprised if he had surgery yeah I mean
I i do when i was around there was no
talk of it but you know he was he was
getting treatment twice a day every
single day since he recover he returned
from that from that knee injury and how
much I I'm sure they're going to
re-evaluate it now that it's over and
see if it got worse or
happened from the you know the the extra
two months of playing on it that he did
and that probably make a decision from
that he's Luke Walton the Lakers head
coach joining us Continental Tire
coaches corner how much were you able to
be involved in laker decisions while you
were coaching during the NBA playoffs um
not not a lot you know the plan was that
I was you know my priorities were to
finish my job with goals they do
everything I could try to help win a
title up there and that was a lot of
time and effort with film and staff
meetings and the Lakers were great about
respecting that and when I did have free
time I would you know I'd be on the
phone with Mitch you know talking about
different things but you know they're
they're the ones that have been down
here in the film room all day in the war
room as they call it watching watching
tape working players out coming in from
college getting ready for the draft so
you know it's it's a team it seems for
it and they're very confident that they
you know they know what they're doing
and they're gonna they're going to have
the right players on the board when it
comes to the draft on thursday if
Simmons goes number one do you know who
you're taking number two no I mean
there's a third I was in there yesterday
for the first first day time and they
they have three or four different you
know mock drafts of how things can play
out and you know just so they're ready
for whatever happens and we'll we'll get
in there today again and I'll have more
time to actually sit in that war room
that there that they have set up and get
answers and and give my opinions
yesterday was a ton of media paperwork
and things like that so today will be
more about the details of the draft
Lakers trying to trade up to get Ben
Simmons was at a possibility
not from my understanding okay i know
you have DeAngelo Russell but you know I
didn't even know if you know there were
any other scenarios or you look at all
scenarios if you say that there's three
or four different scenarios you're
entertaining you know if they take
Simmons then what else would happen you
guys are on the clock at number two so
that's trans I guess they're in the
dough straight there's always trade
offers and you're never going to say
never you know someone wants to trade us
you know you can't say names but
incredible talent superstar is that you
have to entertain that stuff you know
you have to prepare for Ingram goes one
you have to prepare for seven goes one
so there's different things that likely
won't happen but you still have to be
ready for it but again i'll get i'll
know more details on all that stuff when
i get a full day in there today but you
believe that they've had entertained
trade offers for that number two overall
pick I'm sure that they have receipt or
at least had people question asked
questions about what they'd be willing
to take but again that's I don't know
the details on that so I really feel
comfortable commenting on you know on
that but for my understanding date I
haven't heard anything about them trying
to trade up for number one wait you keep
saying they it's we now Luke you got is
we yes we but when me I have a bit of a
warrant so I can't I can't take credit
for what they've done their work out of
out of the week group it is a sub group
that's been an award group i'm calling
this richard jefferson was on a couple
hours ago before the parade and I said
you know you just turned 36 you want a
championship any chance that you would
retire to be an assistant coach on the
Lakers staff here's what Richard
Jefferson had to say no he are Luke uh
yeah I told Luke that I'm retiring I
need a job and he said um he said I
can't he said if you retire you're an
idiot and I can't
idiots on my staff that was that was
that that was pretty much that was the
end of that conversation so now I will
not be joining the laker staff I think
they're doing a great job filling it out
right now is that a direct quote Luke
that is per ticket I'm impressed that he
got it he got it down to he's now having
second thoughts he said I said are you
retiring is I don't know LeBron said I'm
crazy if I retire so he said he's but he
said I I can't go through that emotion
he said it was so draining and I'm
saying he only played 15 minutes a game
imagine if you're LeBron James with
steph curry so yeah I mean he he had an
incredible series hit an incredible year
for you know being being 50 years old
yeah but he you know I think I think
once once it wears off a little bit me
you hit it so hard to win an NBA
championship and he's right it's
draining and it's you you just don't
know if you can do it again I think in a
month from now when he's you know just
relaxing and it's kind of its kind of
hit home and settled down he'll realize
how much fun that was and and how much
he wants to do it again and he's
obviously physically able to keep doing
it and if that's the case you got to
keep playing in my opinion a couple of
months ago Steve Kerr said I asked him
would you have gotten the Lakers job if
Steve wasn't injured and he said
probably not not that that diminishes
you know what you've accomplished or
your abilities to do it but it did it
really take that where you're coaching
the Warriors where people then looked at
you differently did you feel like people
looked at you differently when you took
over on the interim basis yeah i think
so i think just being uh you know i
think with this success we had in Golden
State you know my name would have been
tossed around but there probably would
have still been questions on whether I
could you know am I my age lead lead a
team and those are those are fair
questions asked there's no way to really
know
and I think that would that would have
had the normal process take take longer
you know it was kind of what i thought
would happen anyways no one expects to
get a head coaching job after two years
um but with with Steve going going down
and you know the players stepping up and
having the success we did I think it
kind of said that whole process up a
little bit so if you don't give
Jefferson a spot as an assistant coach
what about Kobe I don't think I I mean
obviously if Kobe wants to come work as
my assistant i would love to boss him
around I mean I he bossed me around for
so many years that I would I would I
even pay you know I'd even pay a little
extra to to be able to be his boss but
I'm picturing Kobe as an assistant coach
I can't really see hey congrats pretty
incredible and you know more importantly
good luck to you and bri with the birth
of the baby there and the draft coming
up and everything else that's going
along with a pretty exciting time look I
appreciate it damn thanks for having me
on I but that's a look what the
Continental Tire Coaches Corner brings
you Luke Walton from Sun to rain to snow
and everything in between continental
tires engineered tire for what you do
extraordinary performance and
reliability but in confidence into
driving for more information in the
location of a dealer near you visit
Continental Tire calm continental tire
for what you do the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience